vous dites en parlant de l'histoire de
l'ilax c'est une histoire vraie est-ce
que c'est la vôtre
bonsoir ça va ça va et vous très bien
vous êtes auteur de théâtre ouais
journaliste culture notamment au Journal
du Dimanche à elle à match et vous
publiez votre premier roman La Femme
interdite chez Jean-Claude latesse alors
c'est un livre sur un sujet tabou qui
touche pourtant des milliers de femmes
en France l'impuissance féminine est-ce
que vous savez ce que c'est
l'impuissance féminine
c'est des femmes qui bandent pas et
c'est logique
on peut vous offrir un verre avec mes
potes parce que il y a rien à boire je
ne savais pas ce que c'était en fait
l'impuissance féminine je l'ai appris en
lisant votre livre d'ailleurs je vois
qu'ici personne ne sait rien à voir avec
la frigidité on en parle la longueur de
magazine toute l'année l'impuissance
féminine on parle jamais c'est marrant
parce que je suis très heureuse bravo
vous avez été droit au but c'est hyper
rare chez un mec en général justement
tout de suite frigidité
ouah la [__] le machin non
ça va réconcilier les hommes et les
femmes je sais pas tout le monde a
entendu dans dans une fin de dîner ou
dans une fin de discussion allez hop
ouais vous voulez nanas vous avez la
chance
il y a une phrase qui dit nous la grotte
est toujours ouverte fort et voilà et
l'impuissance féminine c'est quand la
grotte se ferme voilà si on peut résumer
la chose en deux mots c'est une femme
inviolable en deux mots c'est ça et
c'est un vrai tabou et
ça ramène les femmes à une vraie
existence masculine effectivement
selon où leur enfance ou leur vie
sexuelle ou leur vie affective elle peut
elles peuvent se retrouver avec une
totale en puissance c'est-à-dire un
verrou complet
sur le cœur ou sur le sexe voilà en
impuissance féminine c'est ça certaines
femmes ferment leur vagin excluant par
la même toute pénétration c'est la
définition alors ça s'appelle le
vaginisme en fait mais vous vous
préférez le mot d'impuissance féminine
ouais complètement parce que
bon
le vaginisme a été un mot employé
par certains médecins
qui ne parlaient que d'une douleur
d'une douleur que beaucoup de femmes ont
exprimé à juste titre
et qui était à mon avis
définitivement négative pour l'image de
la femme parce que ça voulait dire une
femme elle n'aime pas faire l'amour avec
un homme ou un problème avec ça
alors que c'est pas ça du tout quoi non
mais à l'opposé de la frigidité
forcément à la manière dont un dont un
aveugle
multiplie c'est possible
dans le toucher dans dans Louis
une femme qui est impuissante va trouver
mille manières d'aimer autrement et donc
va avoir accès non seulement évidemment
à l'orgasme mais à un amour sensuel et
affectif qui va se démultiplier alors
vous abordez le sujet à travers un roman
Le roman déjà c'est un choix important
parce que on a vraiment hésité entre le
document et le roman parce que justement
c'était un sujet jamais traité vraiment
la seule qui a évoqué ça a été madame
Récamier
voilà et qui avait pourtant ni l'amant
elle n'a jamais dit comment elle les
avait ni pourquoi elle les avait mais
c'est un sujet qui est tabou je n'ai
toujours pas compris pourquoi les
magazines féminins hésitaient à en
parler je pense qu'un jour je
comprendrais j'étais moi-même à l'heure
actuelle en promo très étonné que ce
soit
les hommes qui osent en parler et dans
les magazines les plus grands et pas les
magazines féminins et c'est très
intéressant vous dites en parlant de
l'histoire de l'ilax c'est une histoire
vraie est-ce que c'est la vôtre
on parle que de ce qu'on connaît Thierry
évidemment
alors évidemment avec elle les hommes et
c'est tout pour régler son problème
alors il y a ceux qui vont la façon
douce quoi le mec se dit moi je vais y
arriver les caresses cunnilingus etc ça
marche pas il y a aussi la manière forte
il y a un mec qui essaie de la violer en
lui disant tu vas voir cela peut tu vas
aimer ça ça marche pas non plus chaque
fois elle reste seule avec sa douleur
comme une handicapée quoi c'est une
handicapée de l'amour cette fille cette
fille-là c'est une handicapée de l'amour
qui a la force des grandes héroïnes
c'est à dire de choisir de ne pas être
victime et de faire de son handicap une
force d'amour c'est à dire qu'elle va se
tourner vers tous ceux vers qui elle ne
serait jamais allée si elle n'avait pas
eu cette chose là alors elle vit avec un
mec plus âgé qu'elle qui s'appelle Serge
et qui lui est impuissant l'horizon ils
ont développé ensemble une façon
particulière de baiser évidemment parce
que lui il a des pannes elle elle est
impénétrables donc ils ont développé
tout un truc quoi c'est assez étonnant
mais ils ont tout
compris du du ouais du sexe pardon de le
dire
sexualité et après affectivement il y a
mille façons de s'aimer aussi et ce qui
est intéressant c'est qu'après c'est
comme un waouh c'est un radar ça se
développe autour d'eux
il développe une forme d'amour qui est
contagieuse très particulière alors elle
décide à un moment d'aller voir un
docteur un ostéopathe psychanalyste mais
là je vais pas dévoiler la fin voilà moi
je vais pas le dire parce que j'ai
trouvé le bouquin vachement bien et je
vais pas dire la fin parce que est-ce
qu'elle est guérie est-ce qu'elle est
pas guéri comment était le guéri comment
était le pas guéri voilà
je voudrais juste dire que que toute
personne qui se guérit un petit peu
guérit les autres aussi et pour être sûr
de ne rien rater de innarditude
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu